[Music]
when in late february
russia invaded the ukraine a lot of
commentators were struck by how strongly
germany responded against russia and for
ukraine
but we're now 126 days into the war and
the international dynamics are changing
a big concern as wolfgang mounchow
expresses in his cover piece for the
spectator this week
is that germany is going to face a very
cold winter simply because vladimir
putin still holds
enormous power over the country because
of his control of gas and energy
i'm joined now by wolfgang who i should
say is director of euro intelligence
and gideon ratman of the financial times
who is also author of a new book the age
of the strongman
a wolfgang i'll start with you how
worried is germany uh about whether
its support for ukraine can survive uh
what could be a cold winter
uh well they're
at the moment more worried about the
cold winter than than their support for
ukraine
uh what what is happening is that that
putin that the russians have cut the gas
through put to the pipeline system by
about 50 percent
and that means that the germany west as
germany goes into the winter
the gas storage tanks will not be full
they will be half filled they're about
50 percent filled right now and the plan
had been to fill them up to about 100 or
90 percent and then that would be enough
for them to
uh to get through the winter with the
normal gas flows resuming the fear is
that when russia reduced those volumes
that this was the beginning of what
might be a russian gas embargo that
russia might might decide to cut the
volumes now and to either continue
to supply it reduce volumes which is
which would be enough for germany to
have a an energy crisis or actually to
cut the volumes altogether
and then there would be no plan b
germany does not have uh alternative gas
supplies in the short term
uh there would be
over two or three year periods they can
probably do this uh there there have
been talks with the qataris uh but but
these
the there is no capacity uh in qatar for
uh for for further sales to germany the
americans want to supply more more
liquid gas liquid natural gas
uh and they will
but it will not be enough to make up
these enormous shortfalls that would
would result from a nation from a
russian embargo now putin has in the
past not used gas as an as a
geopolitical weapon uh north stream 2
was sort of a long-term strategic thing
for him but it wasn't he never used gas
at least in respect of germany he didn't
use gas he didn't cut the gas in order
to to change uh you know to have to
for political for political reasons but
this is different because the germans
have already said they're going to get
out of russian gas anyway as part of the
eu
eu strategy
so you know jump you know he's not going
to help them get this you know smooth
smooth smooth out of this out of their
russian contracts so he may well be he
may well have an incentive to do this
and the result if he did would be
a very significant energy crisis uh in
germany and the german economics
minister has warned about a lehman style
event a contagious event of people you
know of gas companies and energy
companies failing and causing a ripple
of uh bankruptcies throughout the energy
sector
and of course uh that that reference to
layman's does hint that it might not
just be germany it could be uh could
create a global problem because although
obviously it'd be terribly bad if german
homes can't be heated there's also the
issue of german manufacturing needed to
be powered
it would it would have global impact but
it would certainly be european
uh it would certainly be european uh
economic shock uh the economic impact
assessments are very different economies
have come as often in these cases
different results but the credible ones
that i've been looking at look talk
about a recession to the tune of minus
five to minus seven percent of gdp
that's a lot
if you have these uh if you have these
sort of contagion effects
um
there could be this could this could
ripple through europe
the other thing that that we have the
other problem that we have
is that if if putin cuts the gas to
germany what you know will germany still
supply gas to other eu countries
or you know as they do now because
and is there a solidarity i mean i was
talking about the solidarity with
ukraine in the article but i was all you
know there's another factor of the of
the solidarity between eu members uh
will there be enough eu solidarity to
share the gas that they have or will it
be you know it arrives in my country
first and will use it up and you know if
if you don't have it that's your bad
luck so we have to see about this uh but
it's not exactly a a you know a
solidarity test that people would
probably relish at this point
gideon i'll bring you in um
donald trump uh one of the strong men in
your book uh was much mocked um
when he said things like uh
uh germany is totally controlled by
russia
um however
as we've gone forwards in time uh it
seems like trump had a pretty good point
wouldn't you say well totally controlled
i think is probably overstating it i
mean
as you've seen by the strength of the
german reaction to what uh russia's done
in ukraine in fact they've changed their
foreign policy
really pretty significantly but i think
trump had a point that germany
had over many years unwisely allowed
itself to become
very very reliant on russian gas
they didn't really believe that russia
would ever use this weapon you heard for
example that even throughout the cold
war during crises russia always
continued to supply germany with gas but
now germany itself along with the
european union has decided that this
dependency is too dangerous
and that they're going to wean
themselves off you know a senior german
official said to me a few weeks ago that
putin before the war was looking at 30
years of stable oil and gas revenues
from europe and now he's looking at
three years but those three years could
be very bumpy for the reasons that uh
wolfgang lays out that it's you know
there's it you can't just find new
sources of gas that easily um all the
places they're looking for will either
take time to develop or already
committed so yeah they could have a very
rough winter but from um
you know putin's point of view i could
see why it would be very tempting to do
this pure anger apart from anything else
but there's only one way i think it
works for him strategically is if it
really destabilizes germany so much
that you get a rise of radical parties
such as the afd that are much more
sympathetic to russia and really change
german foreign policy that's one
possible outcome but i think it's just
as likely that it hardens german and
european views that russia is a danger
and we're locked into a long-term
conflict with them so i'm not sure it's
a wise policy for putin to pursue but
then invading ukraine was probably not a
wise policy
so you don't think there's uh do you
think there is a chance that he'd do
this because it would seem to be
further economic suicide from putin to
actually force european countries we've
talked about moving away from gas for a
long time but not actually done it to
move away to alternative sources of
energy yeah i mean who knows but um you
know we've all kind of go or a lot of
people have got what was in his head
wrong
uh he may just be waving the weapon in
in the hope that this will force or
persuade the europeans to put more
pressure on ukraine to
to come to the negotiating table
but i suppose you could also argue from
the russian point of view in a sense
they've already inflicted this strategic
loss on themselves they know that uh if
the europeans are as good as their word
and can follow through that the russian
sales of gas to europe will end in about
three to five years and that's a big
problem for them because they don't have
the pipeline capacity yet to redirect it
to china and as we saw with nordstrom 2
constructing these new pipelines takes
many many years so maybe it's a sort of
scenario where he says well you've
damaged us we're going to try and damage
you but um
you know i just don't know i mean people
will have thought it through
probably quite carefully it's
interesting talking to sort of senior
executives of the oil and gas
multinationals who say that talking to
putin was like talking to one of their
peers he had an incredible command of
the oil and gas industry and russian
economics but obviously the bigger
picture for him is geopolitical and he
doesn't have that many good options to
be honest i you know
as you were saying russia is doing a bit
better in the war now but if you look at
their strategic
overall picture you know if this war was
about nato enlargement well sweden and
and finland have just you know been
agreed to join nato so nato's had its
biggest enlargement for a very long time
and um obviously the russian economy is
shrinking they've taken big losses on
the battlefield so
he's got a few
tactics he can use but strategically i
think he's in a bad spot
wolfgang you touched on nuclear power
the greens are in germany's governing
coalition now
and they do not want to um stop the
commitment to to
eliminating nuclear power uh and
presumably they do not want to go back
to coal
uh as a source of german energy
how much are environmental concerns
getting in the way of dealing with what
is a a serious looming emergency in the
energy sector
frank thank you for the question i'm
going to answer it in a in a few seconds
but let me just make one additional
comment to
what what gideon says and i think is is
his analysis is right that putin doesn't
have uh you know put in putin's you know
putin may be over very much over playing
his hand but we we have to consider two
factors here first of all he got himself
an awful lot of money through the rise
in oil and gas prices
i i you know i've sort of been doing the
maths on what his likely current account
surplus is likely to be this year and
we're looking at 200 to 250 billion euro
dollars and that's almost as much as the
money we throw as the assets the west
have frozen
uh this is a huge amount of money and
the the gas sales are still very
profitable for him especially now that
the gas prices are rising as a result of
his decision to cut the throughput uh he
will make more money by selling less
cars that is quite a possible possible
thing but he is in a position to afford
it
uh he is not
you know he his problem is spending the
cash it's not getting it
um and the in the medium term is
strategic option
uh is very much to to supply
uh uh the the the parts of the world
that are not the west you know africa
india china
he's got you know there are a number of
countries that would still
buy russian products and that might also
supply russia with electrical components
the one that he is really not getting
from the west
asking about getting back to your
question on the nuclear on the nuclear
power for the greens i mean if you sort
of you're sitting here in the uk and if
you you know you would you wouldn't
think twice about this because nuclear
power seems to be you know these are
the
german nuclear power stations are some
of the safest in the world they're built
of the highest standards
there's nothing wrong with us the power
stations that are being that are being
decommissioned now they're still that
the three are still running and supply
about six percent of the electricity
with all this stuff happening you would
probably not want to have another you
know shortfall of electricity on top of
the gas situation so it would be a
rational almost a no-brainer
however if you know if you understand
the history of the green party it was
their opposition to nuclear power
that uh you know that got them into
politics uh this is the the this is sort
of as
principled and and as as difficult for
them an issue as like you know europe
was for the conservative party it's not
something that they can easily just dump
and say okay well we'll do it and you
know it's it's because it's rational and
robert harbeck clearly you know
i don't think he would have a strong
personal view on this matter and as an
economics minister he's probably
you know he knows the he knows the
numbers and he will probably say fine we
will do this but as a as a politician
he
would struggle to
to do this unless he he had no other
choice so the the what i think is going
to happen is they will definitely not
discuss this at the moment but should
putin cut the gas and should there be a
mayhem and you know and
he might just ask his party you know
shall we keep the nuclear power stations
running for another three years or shall
we start commissioning coal what do you
think i think he might just get away
with the with the prolongation of the of
the power station i actually would go
further because there have been three
stations cut at the end of last year
that can still be recommissioned as
possible technically
there are legal obstacles as you know in
germany everything is always legal
obstacles but technically they could
actually get 12 to 13 of electricity
uh back online and that's quite a lot uh
that to me would have been the the most
logical uh
emergency plan to to fix a a a you know
clear and present danger because 10 is a
lot of a lot of energy
uh that you would have to replace in a
in a in a period when gas
and oil and coal is
hugely expensive so you know these these
discussions will be have i'm i'm told
the three
the three
nuclear
stations from from last year will stay
shut because nobody has the appetite to
go through a protracted legal battle but
i would still think that the ones that
are still operational today
uh that those are possibly still in play
despite of what you what you're hearing
officially
your book is about how strong men such
as putin uh are
increasingly sort of defined global
politics in the 21st century and when
you look at this relationship between
russia and germany does it not suggest
that strong men leaders
uh have advantages in a time of rising
geo-strategic tensions um they have
advantages over uh democratically
elected people and
more democratically elected people and
the pressures they face at home well
we'll see i mean you know i would
in my book i've been often accused of
being excessively gloomy but i i think
that
you know arguably what putin has done in
ukraine actually reveals the weakness of
a strongman style system because uh
there was nobody to say to him look this
is crazy or you've got to get through
this this through parliament
things were so centralized around him
that he was able to take a decision that
even his own foreign minister apparently
didn't really know about until the day
before
um so
and it looks like for the reasons i set
out that
it will be a big
strategic uh setback for russia that's
putting mildly not to speak of the kind
of economic and political cultural
aspects of it so i think
you know
yes he has more he has the ability to
make rapid decisions to maneuver quickly
in this situation but he also has the
ability
to inflict a disaster on his country
which i think he's done
and by contrast i mean i think that
although clearly uh you know you can
point at all these arguments about
nuclear power and say for god's sake
this is ridiculous we should be able to
move quicker actually i think that the
democratic countries of the west move
pretty fast uh
you know in imposing now six packages of
sanctions uh these are you know 27 eu
countries the uk the us
canada japan australia south korea all
came together um and
slightly confounded the image of this
sort of slow moving democratic west that
was unable to get its act together
wolfgang and gideon we'll end it there
but thank you very much indeed for
coming on
[Music]
you